[Música]
washington a taxa é o caso agora é só
dar essa força do carnaval
a pergunta e aí galera que se chama
ronaldo bom vocês aí pro carnaval é bom
eu sou muito bebeu no item assaltado não
foi assaltada assalto alguém ainda vai
pensar o fruto é doida tentam passar
porque há 50 anos a música mais tocada
ei você aí me dá um dinheiro aí me dá um
dinheiro aí é de brasília tem show é dia
4 de março no ginásio nilson nelson às
20 horas está em graça que nesse site
esquece de brasília natal de 24 de março
a arena das dunas nesse site dava para
ingresso está não esquece as pessoas
fazem muitos falam muitas coisas verdade
de risco de pobre mas sabe o que é
porque eu vivenciei todo tudo isso e ver
se os dois lados da moeda porque tudo
rio o bope tem uma diferença na casa do
rico já é diferente da casa do porto na
casa do rio é diferente da casa do povo
não quer dizer que a casa do pobre seja
arrumadinha não mas as coisas a
estrutura usar salto de fred o exemplo
comida comida como diferente que eu ia
pra casa os meus primo e observei que
fique rico tem uma dificuldade de comer
pode ter dificuldade como é que a
carteira cheia de coisas do que o
mercado pode não pode abrir pra comer
pergunta 0 de bem com média de mim nem a
ninguém ligar que antes tinha até fap
por isso que o filho ricky na hora do
almoço assistindo à pepe está assistindo
a aventureira quer que o filho pode
assistindo aos jogos super choque está
passando a 5 anos o pessoal tá passando
assim quando os mesmos episódios meses
episódio gente já sabe as falas
decoradas alimentício que super shopping
é a mãe do rei vai bota o prato menino
lindo o prato lindo aquele prato
bonitinho que tem divisórias lugar de
batatal por eta é um lugar em botas
nego-me teu lugar de qual carro 8
kompensan quase igual ao longo de 2010
ele gostou ele fixo a casa vira temática
do desembargador
peguei a colherzinha ep pague mais
chocado que eu criei minha do pobre tem
prato da pbr tem pra só pra na casa do
pobre ter sido praticado pode ter dois
tipos de prato prato de visita e o
prático em casa chegou a visita o prato
novo embora a visita àqueles prática o
vidro só quando vidro é co a mim do
rigor do desenho pronto virou tudo até
piga a casa fica com 10 ainda pepe o
quarto é a escola de banda pepe gatusa é
da pb e do ben 10 anos e que tocar diz
aí minha casa a temática também do super
chef tomada mercado e descascado era só
o que tinha que me virar ao super choque
anac para domingo rica uma besteira pra
comer que tem tudo pra comer mas não
come há um prato cheio de coisa tem uma
coxa por menina koch gigante ele pega o
cheque com a mão a ele morre aqui ó
morte outro lado e deixa lá aí fica coxa
aqui modificar desse lado monte carlo
desse lado o ocorrido não me parece bem
como formação e no começo qual fica
indignado filho do pobre coxa eu eu vim
conheceu a coxa tinha 15 16 anos atacado
porque come coxa o pai só e não como
igual à massa no ícone tudo come tudo
que olha para ele tal como no outro
então vou continuar rígido a mãe usando
um super herói pra fazer a criança com
meirelles ea banquinho como jerry se tem
que se alimentar e ir um homem que
alegou que meu deus menino como olha o
um quiser telefone se você não comer
você não vai ser fácil igual o que é bom
a 1.500 eu fosse me basear em seu último
ri porque assistiu super shopping são
josé fica forte com um super show que é
amor é apegado à tomada há muito pobre e
insiste ela pergunta três vezes só vai
comigo não vai não vai comer não emprega
banheiro da casa rita é doido ebony mais
cara duas pia melhor coisa que tem no
mundo são duas pior que cada um para sua
coisa ali vocês call center desse lado
eu escovo desse outro aí o que acontece
não ficam escovando um outro boca foi
falando aqui ó irritou muito bom e tem
banheiro do casal tamanho de visita em
um banheiro da área de serviço e
banheiro do filho no quarto do filho
para poder comer
as caldas de ginkgo um crime de tal
sabor de uva cada povo só tem um
banheiro e um cara acorda às 6 horas da
manhã crítica vai ser o primeiro a
chegar no banheiro quando ele chega
perto da porta do banheiro tem uma fila
aparece uma casa lotérica aquela pessoa
encontrada para cada um com sua toalha
ea pessoa que chegou primeiro para cá
não caga direito não quem está do lado
de fora esperando para tomar banho fica
botando pressão pessoa carol ó o celular
foi pagar também a eu freei
a escola é mãe cleide não saiba não há
pois que o papel impresso preparar para
ver que a maioria das pessoas nunca nem
com gente perto pobre ele cresceu foi o
cagão pressão da família eu fico nervosa
é muita pressão da família para eu
passar no vestibular de medicina graveto
levar pressão nakagawa amor que tem
muito diferente do banheiro do rico do
pobre é o shampoo e um xampu do rio se
você prestar atenção quando se bater na
mão e desce cremoso é o fenerbahçe país
aqui ele desce aquele creme parece leite
moça o xampu do povo não lhe falta é
cuspir em você você bota houve pé da
porta do banheiro não pode ser só vai
escutar esse aqui ó
o shampoo e não cai na sua moeda e cospe
na sua mão
esses são os últimos momentos do xampu
últimos momentos até botar um pouco de
água para aproveitar o xampu tempo
internet
o zinho do rio incluindo ricardo quirino
você chega na buzina do rio você procura
ao meu deus onde está o fogão onde está
o fogão onde está o fogão não tem fogão
as etapas para estar mais pobre do
caminho porque não tem fogão aí você
olha no balcão tem uma árvore de um
fogão embutido no balcão a geladeira cor
grafite e duas portas abrissem que num
armário que você olha tem que ligar um
delay de galão de leite para jardim é
jardim jardim a cozinha do pop você é
pois bem notável tudo tem capa todos os
eletrodomésticos têm roupa material está
coberto com a roupinha feito batedeira
liquidificador ele está coberto o
butijão de gás tem uma capinha uma delas
é nem do crato tem roupinhas e botas a
batedeira liquidificador botijão de gás
e eu para ficar irmão que vez que o
botijão de gás que a roupa melhor
caminho em botijão de gás sempre tem
mais em forma do governo então as roupas
melhor carro melhore até a cozinha vem
passando um gato gato rica fácil
conhecer aquele gato muito peludo na
cara batida tem que resgatem cá
de tédio é pura paixão ele faz aqui ó
o gato do pobre é fácil conhecer só com
teclas urubu de gato em cima do trf ward
e ficam aí tem uma gata e setenta e
cinco gatos nasce um gato 75 ou e
castanho preto a ponta do rabo do gato é
assim ó quebraduras homem aparece com 20
dias cego a cozinha do rico em cobre
todo o plantel cop efe gerante tem um
copo de vinho copo de uísque copo de
água a do pop em 2 com o copo grande e
os copos de extrato de tomate e copo bob
rivet vai brindar essa onde é nossas
empresas e medo sim do bairro ea raquel
kops tap tomar de volta pela mesa no
chão ele quebra o chão conquistar de
tomada do mesmo fabricante da nokia é
copo bom eu acho que não tava vendendo a
empresa e preso no meu deus não estamos
vendendo copo que a gente pode fazer ao
local já as equipes do botafogo estado
de tomate do copom ea humanidade abraçou
nessa forma maravilhosa tem casa que tem
35 40 44 na quitinete anotações
conquistado em tomar canga e você
conhece não tem como disfarçar aquela
estrada tomada ea casa está tomada a
gente quer tirar o rótulo para parecer
que está tomada mas quando você puxa o
rótulo fica aquela marca branca para
você não esquecer você é pobre e pode
pegar um boom prius e volta do stj sabor
de sabão em pó taf do sul furico se
esfrega aquele negócio branco ali eles
ao negócio branco ele fica cola como
está tendo assim e não fugir da pobreza
o nano tem negado as torres kio atacante
tirar o rótulo não é negócio de não ser
público tem como disfarçar é impossível
não tem como disfarçar de chegou amigo
meu em casa tirando onda com migas copa
que está de tomate é destaque tomate ou
demitir não é não é copa que é de estar
de tomate sim eu disser não antes esse
copo é de extrato de tomate de senão ele
disse é de quem eu disse
e requeijão powell tem preconceito tira
onda com carga de copos de extrato de
tomate o milan na escola ninguém lá em
casa tem um copo de vinho lá em casa tem
copo de uísque lá em casa tem copos de
leite na sua casa tem cópia de que eu
disse de vidro apetite da casa de rico
já fui na capa o filho caçula santino um
tapete que é de fora fora ou amar linda
do mundo o livro está pensando que nem
pisar a esse tapete que comprou um fiat
uno certeza macio aveludada foi lançando
que a troca está pensando na minha cama
a perder pobre a camisa de político
ponha campanha na casa henrique alencar
na gosto de ouvir se apega na campanha
faz playbutton é que houve a campanha da
scor visita só não tem campanha na
campanha da casa do povo é o cachorro a
mulher aqui conversando com outra pois é
meu e eu comprei no carnê
aí quando chegou
quem é que disse que não e não importa a
casa que você viu o importante é dar
valor às pessoas que você ama seu pai e
sua mãe seus amigos é isso aí você
mostrar esse vídeo com gostei aqui tá
não sabe que sempre gostei que é muito
importante pra mim você já quer fechar
aqui já que a apple do vídeo jaqueline
gostei anos comenta aqui embaixo que
você quer mais que eu faço em casa de
pobre rapaz e que carro de ricardo e
paulo faz sei lá a descoberta em baixa e
volta lá no facebook eu postei vídeo
novo casa de rico casa de pobre porque o
link do youtube e curti lá não se
esquece de curtir marca seu amigo dos
comentários que viram alguma dessas duas
vidas aí alguma dessas duas casas marca
nos comentários aí nas redes sociais na
descrição do vídeo aqui twitter
instagram facebook também também que vai
comprar o ingresso
brasília 4 de março deu entrada no site
lá tamo junto é nóis um beijão